thanks for joining us America Gayle is
with us in Allentown Pennsylvania hi
Gail how are you hi Dave I'm good thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up well kind of similar to
your last caller except for I'm dealing
with a 24 year old who just doesn't want
to keep a job and my husband and I have
been we've all Larry Burkett now we
follow your plan
he has two retirements working on a
third job I work so my son comes from a
family who we've always worked always
save money we only have 50 left on our
house we have about 48 to 50 in debt
which is probably mostly my fault I
co-signed for a car for my son I just I
can't get past telling him no he is a
father now he gets his son three days a
week we've gone as far as on the tough
love as he can't live in our house
anymore can't do it he doesn't follow
rules it gets just very obnoxious and he
just can't do it so I guess when he
calls crying hip his rent and this
doesn't know where he's going to live
the next day or the baby needs diapers
milk I don't know what I'm going to do
for the next three days you know there's
mom to rescue and I feel like right now
like instead of helping my husband pay
off some of the mess that I started or
and get the house paid off which he
wanted to do before he retired which we
didn't do I feel like I'm working to pay
for my son's living and I'm just I know
as soon as they know but I'm just I
can't get rid of that guilt and I'm just
looking for some help I think I can help
because I think you need to replace your
guilt with real guilt let me help you
with that you have not helped your son
you have hurt him great any time you
give him money and any time you coddle
him like he's a four-year-old you're
hurting him you're not helping him
you're doing you've done great harm to
him as he's now under the illusion he
can live like this every time you give
every time you give him money you are
hurting your son okay
so feel guilty if you give him money
okay feel proud and good day if you
don't give him money because you're
being a loving mother yeah see the
problem is this enablers are the nicest
people on the planet you're sweet you
are a sweet person you have a kind and
compassionate heart and enablers are the
people who get help confused they define
help wrong you have a wrong definition
of help you feel like when you're giving
him money you're helping him and when in
reality you're hurting him you feel like
when you are not giving him money that
you are not helping him when in reality
you're actually helping him great you've
defined help think about that you have
to find helpful okay and it's because
you're sweet it's not because you're a
bad person
it's just you're a sweet person but you
you know that what that leads you to is
your own inability to say no and every
time you say yes in this situation you
have brought him and you and your
husband harm you co-sign for a stupid
car which your husband told you not to
do and Larry Burkett told you not to do
and Dave Ramsey told you not to do and
you did it anyway knowing that this kid
was a deadbeat and doesn't work much
mm-hmm you knew it was going to blow up
in your intellect great when you did it
anyway you walked right in little family
well how did he get to work and go to
work how did you come up with all this
crap in your head but you lay your hand
on a hot stove and then you're shocked
you touch and burn exactly so you know
you need to redefine help okay and if
you read to find help you'll feel guilty
every time you give him money because
you'll know you're hurting your son
you've done him harm it's not
irreparable harm he can be turned but
you've done him harm because he has a
wrong view of what it takes to make it
in this world and part of that is
because his mommy bails him out and
that's not me being mean that's me
helping you redefine guilt Wayne I want
you to feel guilty if you give him money
I want you to feel convicted if you give
him money because you're hurting him
right
he's Spartan he has no work ethic the
worst part is I know that I just like
when I'm working a midnight shift as a
nurse he's calling me because he's in
his car there's nowhere to go you know
I'm like just pretend like when he does
that that he's calling you and asking
you to go to the to go and give him
money for cocaine right you would never
do that why because cocaine would
destroy his life Craig and you would
never give him money to destroy his life
and you are mama Rick I need some
cocaine please my lunches lifespan if
you don't get me some coke Aydin gonna
be okay you would laugh brain at the
absurdity of that and so replace his
request for money rooted in your mind
with replace Rick with requests for
cocaine because it's the same thing
you're its harm in other words that
that's where we're redefining help with
you and you got to realize you're
bringing him harm as if you were buying
him cocaine every time you reinforce his
lack of work ethic and his sniveling and
whining and crying as a 24 year old
little boy instead of being a man what
were you doing when you were 24 what was
your husband doing he was 24 I sure
wasn't calling home to my mommy asking
for money exactly I toned that all the
time I was actually a single mother with
him working two jobs and I own that all
the time and I'm like yeah I'm busy and
he's a goal well today's not like that
you can't make as much money to live off
of like I'm like I was a single mom when
you not understand I didn't have welfare
I didn't have food dance or anything I
was doing it on my own with you so you
need to help and okay so that your
husband is a stepdad yes but raised
basically raised him yes yes put a
little toddler up as raised him like you
need to set yourself home need to set
yourself in our accountability
relationship with your husband regarding
how you're treating your son and you can
never give him any more money for
cocaine okay
is that is that logical to you grasp
around kind of how I'm going at this yes
that's that's what I needed
it's not just love it's love brain
everybody's watched tough love it's not
tough love it's just love I love him so
much that
know if he doesn't fix this he's gonna
have a horrible life and he is his life
sucks because he has no discipline he
does everything on impulse
he has no manhood he's a little boy in a
24 year old body and if he doesn't grow
up until he grows up is the best way of
saying it his life is going to continue
to suck and you can't fix it because
every time you try to fix it he makes it
worse is this right yep okay I'm gonna
send you a book that's one of my
favorite on the subject by a man named
dr. Henry cloud it's called boundaries
okay and what's happening here is is
you're not that you don't have good
healthy boundaries and that's what all
enablers do and I'm not a psychologist I
just know this stuff because I've dealt
with it for so many years and oh by the
way I've done stuff like this too so
okay it's not like it's not like I've
got this all figured out and I'm perfect
don't misunderstand but we all love
people and we can get confused when we
love them between helping them and
hurting them right and we really can we
can do that and so I want you to feel as
guilty as if you had bought him a pound
of cocaine every time you give him money
from this point forward you should never
give him it you should never give him
another dime okay you can love him you
can have him come over for dinner um you
know we'll babysit the kid occasionally
the baby that the grandchild and put
diapers on them when they're here um and
if you're homeless you know we'll help
with the baby but we're not helping with
you right cause it's time for you to be
a man my son right your manhood it's
time for Justin to come and to show up
you being a grown-up and and you know
part of the problem with this whole
story is the his arrogance that's tied
in to his rebellion here so all right
cool hold on Kelly I'll pick up I and
she'll give you a free copy of dr. Henry
clouts book boundaries and we'll mail it
out to you I just love that book because
it's just it's where you learn these
basic ways of operating our lives it's
weird that family questions
are dominating the airwaves today but
then again it's not really weird we all
struggle with these things don't we some
are more extreme than others but you
know I never hear me being mean to that
24 year old now call him names and I'll
pick on him to implant in his mother's
mind emotionally what she needs to do
but if he called me up I would say dude
you're being a worse suck it up get six
jobs feed your baby buy some diapers you
can do it you can do it I'd call him out
on it they call me on the air so this is
why because I want him to win this is
the Dave Ramsey show